irving gets inside oh
beautiful move from kyrie irving
by kyrie irving i i say this taking the
defense to church
make him throw his hands up and then you
finish
doesn't even see the rim the ability to
hang in the air
and find the answer the solution to the
problem to make this a very very long
night
for the brooklyn nets west brook is now
seven of 11 from the field
oh durant that is a man's jam
[Applause]
this goes around two and dunks on the
third
oh come on you got your seven foot two
guard knocking down shots duck
the nets forced the turnover harden oh
what a bounce for
green james harden
he's at another level this is just
absolutely filthy through four players
right in stride the eyes
the overhead look at that i'm here
james hart makes it look too easy long
rebound controlled by durant
that's running the floor hard durant the
bounce leads irving
oh the english he put it high
off the window kyrie irving
opportunity for a finish here by the
nets and kyrie irving
up under high off the glass from the
opposite side
that is astounding oh this is cold look
at this
his hang and it's his vision and focus
that he remains no matter how his body
is contorting
his eyes are always focused over three
[Applause]
from downtown the other night here's
durant for the greens crossover alliance
and hits plus the foul
and marv the crowd is getting into it
but hustle plays griffin continue
continues with that performance great
anticipation great lift
for the old fella with the tip dunk and
kd get into his bag
find his rhythm draws the foul brooklyn
up early it's a one-point game
let's find themselves in another
potentially hairy situation
harden goes long green ball fake layup
is good and a foul
with 5.5 hardin throws the touchdown
pass
to jeff green talk about redemption
brooklyn in the same position they were
in two nights ago
jeff green wide open and it looked like
he didn't even really want to shoot that
right there but
knocks down the layup great pass by
hardin
another assist from him they lost to
dallas
in the nba finals amongst other
illustrations of that
irving spins on the baseline elevates
and cut one underneath wow come on this
guy is so special
to do well on the offensive glass i
don't care who the defender is that's
bledsoe who's been a
all-nba defensive player mismatch it's
one on one with kyrie
good luck he's at the 11 second
different shot clock to game clock
dotson loses it walking the tightrope
oh blake griffin razzle dazzle oh
next level kevin durant
the rack attack and one of the
highlights of the year
[Applause]
play of the year in the regular season
finale
razzle dazzle flavor and bring
[Applause]
uh oh get ready play-offs are coming
patty mills misses from three-point
territory claxton the rebound gets rid
of it quickly for harden i did see that
movie
oh you did a couple times reese
witherspoon oh the jumper goes
james harden and the foul
chef's kiss
[Applause]
oh it's getting too good here look at
this the step back
the finish like loves it yeah we do
two bgs
all right look at him jeff green
gets it into durant here is durant
moving on tucker
he turns he shoots yes
with one second remaining
one second left the
[Applause]
what an incredible shot by
kevin durant
[Applause]
[Applause]
if the replay has confirmed
gathers his feet the question is was his
toe on the line and it looks like from
that angle
it was on the line still a beautiful
shot by durant off balance fading away
tucker in his face and able to
concentrate
and step up and knock down that shot but
from that angle marv it looked like
definitely toe on the line and depending
upon what happens is
what they called in this last second we
might be in for overtime